pierre moscovici sera nommé mercredi
premier président de la cour des comptes
par emmanuel macron l'ex ministre des
finances socialiste sous le quinquennat
françois hollande succède à didier
migaud à 62 ans il fait son retour en
france après avoir été notamment
commissaire européen aux affaires
économiques
l'automne il avait démissionné il était
parti à l'automne dernier nombreuses
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux suite
à cette nomination
nommé moscovici premier président de la
cour des comptes et un une honte pour la
france 2 le choix d'un courtisan
incapables qui dira oui à tout 3 la
prolongation de la casse des services
publics en france 4 une marque du
transfert de souveraineté à l'union
européenne
5 tout ça à la fois tiens moscovici la
personne qui n'a pas récupéré 2,2
milliards d'euros que la société
générale doit rendre depuis l' affaire
kerviel chargée de s'assurer du bon
emploi de l'argent public et d'en
informer les citoyens et citoyennes
j'ai comme un doute que l'on passe un
accord avec wauquiez pour les
municipales à lyon
moscovici nommé à la cour des comptes
après avoir parlé de populisme
mainstream au sujet de macron voilà ce
que produit le soi-disant nouveau monde
nous avons moins de deux ans pour
tourner la page quand tu veux que rien
ne se sache tu nommes un camarade à la
tête de la cour des comptes
[Musique]